OK, so we're going to start this week's show with something that's been going on behind the scenes of this year's midterm election. It's called the precinct strategy. This is something that's been around for a while, but it wasn't a big thing until last year when Steve Bannon-- remember, Steve Bannon?-- got a hold of the idea and started pushing it on his podcast.
好的，这周的节目我们要从今年中期选举幕后发生的事情开始说起。这被称为“选区策略”。这个概念存在已久，但直到去年斯蒂夫·班农——还记得斯蒂夫·班农吗？——抓住这个想法并在他的播客上大力推广后，才变得广为人知。
So, Dan, the floor is yours. You're about to offer a course on personal political empowerment. How did they do it, Dan?
那么，丹，现在交给你了。你准备开设一门关于个人政治赋权的课程。丹，他们是怎么做到的？
This right here is the video that started it off. It's from February 2021, just Steve Bannon being the Steve Bannon we've come to know. He's wearing at least three shirts. He's framed by a row of MAGA hats lined up on a mantel. And he's bringing on this guest, who is a long time Arizona activist named Dan Schultz.
这就是开启这一切的视频。它来自2021年2月，视频里是大家熟悉的那个斯蒂夫·班农。他穿着至少三件衬衫，背景壁炉上摆着一排“让美国再次伟大”（MAGA）的帽子。他请来了一位嘉宾，一位来自亚利桑那州的资深活动家，丹·舒尔茨。
Dan Schultz is here to solve a problem.
丹·舒尔茨来到这里是为了解决一个问题。
Thanks, Steve. It's real simple, and most people learn this-- at least I did-- back in the late '60s, in seventh grade in social studies, in civics class.
谢谢，斯蒂夫。其实很简单，大多数人在60年代末上七年级社会课或公民课时都学过这个——至少我是这样。
OK, so what he lays out here, the way that Schultz and Bannon see this, the reason that Donald Trump isn't president anymore, it's not just election fraud by the Democrats. That's obviously a given for them. But the real problem in 2020 was the Republicans who let them get away with it, who didn't do every last thing in their power to keep President Trump in office.
好的，他在这里阐述的观点是，舒尔茨和班农认为，唐纳德·特朗普之所以不再是总统，不仅仅是因为民主党人的选举欺诈——对他们来说这是不言而喻的——真正的问题在于2020年那些让民主党得逞的共和党人，他们没有竭尽全力让特朗普总统留在职位上。
What they're talking about is the mainstream Republicans in Arizona and Georgia and Michigan, people who went ahead and certified the election results for Joe Biden, accepted that Trump lost, did not stand by him in his neediest hour. To prevent that from happening again, Dan Schultz and Steve Bannon want an army of MAGA enthusiasts to be in place and be ready for the coming election in just a few weeks.
他们指的是亚利桑那州、佐治亚州和密歇根州的主流共和党人，正是这些人认证了乔·拜登的选举结果，接受了特朗普败选的事实，没有在他最需要的时候支持他。为了防止这种情况再次发生，丹·舒尔茨和斯蒂夫·班农希望在短短几周后的选举中，有一支MAGA拥护者大军能够就位并做好准备。
And they're going to do this by getting people to sign up for the lowest level positions in the Republican Party. It's a job called precinct committeeman.
他们打算通过让人们报名参加共和党内最低级别的职位来实现这一目标。这个职位叫作“选区委员”。
I've got my PC button on it, precinct committeeman. Precinct committeemen are the party. And if you want to put up graphic number four, it basically explains that there's about 400,000 of these party positions in our party nationwide. But over 200,000 of them are vacant. What we have to do is, we have to take over the party. And there's only one way to do it. The precinct committeemen are the party.
我戴着我的PC（选区委员）徽章。选区委员就是党的基础。如果把第四张图表放出来，上面基本上解释了全国约有40万个这样的党内职位，但超过20万个处于空缺状态。我们必须做的是接管这个党。只有一种方法可以做到：选区委员就是党。
Precinct committeemen do all kinds of political grunt work-- door knocking, phone banking, leafleting. They often work as official poll watchers on election day for the party. But in addition, and this might not sound like a big deal but it's key-- they often elect officials higher up in the Republican Party, who elect the officials even higher up than that, who elect the state parties and the national party and decide where GOP is going to spend money and what races to back, they decide the party platform. They determine what the party officially stands for.
选区委员负责各种政治苦差事——挨家挨户敲门、打电话拉票、发传单。他们通常在选举日担任党的官方监票员。此外——这听起来可能没什么大不了，但却是关键——他们经常选举共和党内更高级别的官员，后者再选举更高级别的官员，最终选出州党部和全国党部，决定共和党将资金花在哪里、支持哪些竞选，并决定党的纲领。他们决定了共和党正式代表什么。
These are the jobs at the bottom that Steve Bannon wants to fill with people who believe that the last election was stolen, people who are very excited at the chance to do something, anything to prevent an election from being stolen again. And Bannon has kept the drumbeat going for months and months to get MAGA Stop the Steal people to sign up for these jobs.
这些就是斯蒂夫·班农想要填补的最底层职位，他希望填补这些职位的人是那些相信上届选举被窃取的人，是那些渴望做点什么——任何事都可以——来防止选举再次被窃取的人。班农几个月来一直敲锣打鼓，号召“停止窃选”的MAGA支持者们去竞选这些职位。
For instance, in August, Bannon polled the audience of the Moment of Truth Summit in Missouri, which was hosted by Mike Lindell, the MyPillow guy who's turned election conspiracy theorist.
例如，在八月，班农在密苏里州的“真理时刻峰会”上对观众进行了民意调查，该峰会由已转为选举阴谋论者的“枕头哥”迈克·林德尔主持。
Look, how many guys here are precinct committeemen? Look at that. Wow. Everybody stand up. Stand up if you're precinct committeemen.
听着，这里有多少人是选区委员？看看吧。哇。大家都站起来。如果是选区委员就站起来。
Oh my god.
天哪。
Look at that. Wow.
看看那个。哇。
A few weeks back, Bannon asked one of his correspondents at a Trump rally in Pennsylvania to poll a group of supporters there.
几周前，班农让他的一位记者在宾夕法尼亚州的一次特朗普集会上对支持者进行民意调查。
OK, question from Steve to everybody here. How many of you are precinct committeemen, or how many of you are going to become precinct committeemen to take over the Republican Party? We've got one, two.
好的，斯蒂夫给在座各位的问题。你们当中有多少人是选区委员，或者有多少人打算成为选区委员来接管共和党？我们有一个，两个。
I'm a precinct committeeman.
我是选区委员。
I'm a judge of elections.
我是选举法官。
Judge of elections. We got three.
选举法官。我们有三个。
And I ran for state committee, but we got two people in out of 16.
我竞选了州委员会，但16人里我们只进去了两个。
OK, so we got four. Anyone else? And if you aren't yet, you got to do it. This is the key, guys. And to the audience out there, Steve says it every day, but this is the key. You can't just come out here and fly your flags. You got to get in the fight.
好的，现在有四个了。还有其他人吗？如果还没加入，你们必须去做。这是关键，伙计们。对于外面的听众，斯蒂夫每天都在说，这才是关键。你们不能只在这里挥舞旗帜，你们必须参与战斗。
Knock on doors, make phone calls, go to the elections offices. Take over the Republican Party. We have to MAGA the Republican Party.
敲门、打电话、去选举办公室。接管共和党。我们必须让共和党再次伟大（MAGA）。
The person who first reported that there's this surge of new Stop the Steal recruits becoming precinct committeemen around the country for the Republican Party was Isaac Arnsdorf. He was at Propublica when he did that. These days, he's a politics reporter at the Washington Post. And he's been tracking this takeover of the Republican Party in swing states all over the country.
最早报道全国各地出现这种“停止窃选”新招募者加入共和党成为选区委员浪潮的人是艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫。他当时在ProPublica任职。如今，他是《华盛顿邮报》的政治记者。他一直在跟踪全国各摇摆州共和党的这种接管行动。
He allowed us to tag along with him. We were happy to go. He and one of our producers, Zoe Chace, hit the road together to see how the presence of these Stop the Stealers is changing things. If they get their way, it's going to shift the party and the way we do elections pretty fundamentally for years to come. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
他让我们随行报道，我们很高兴能去。他和我们的制作人之一佐伊·蔡斯一起上路，看看这些“停止窃选”者是如何改变现状的。如果他们得逞，将在未来几年从根本上改变这个党和我们的选举方式。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, Magazona. So today on our show, we're going to look at how all this is playing out in Arizona, a place that some MAGA people like to call Magazona. And we chose Arizona because the movement there has really been setting the pace for the rest of the country.
第一幕，“MAGA亚利桑那”。今天在我们的节目中，我们将探讨这一切如何在亚利桑那州上演，一些MAGA人士喜欢称其为“MAGA亚利桑那”。我们选择亚利桑那州，是因为那里的运动确实为全国其他地区设定了步调。
People who believe the 2020 election was stolen tried to recall Republican officials there. They also pushed for a hand recount of millions of ballots that became a model for other states around the country who tried it.
相信2020年选举被窃取的人们试图在当地罢免共和党官员。他们还推动了数百万张选票的手工重新计票，这成为全国其他尝试此举州的典范。
Even though in Arizona it revealed that Joe Biden won the election with even more votes than they had thought, the audit in Arizona galvanized tons of people who wanted to do more. And lots of those people jumped into the precinct strategy.
尽管在亚利桑那州的审计结果显示乔·拜登赢得的选票甚至比预想的还要多，但这却激发起无数想要做更多事情的人。其中许多人加入了“选区策略”。
So in Arizona, you can really see the effect that strategy is having. That is what Isaac and Zoe have been out there co-reporting. Here's Isaac.
所以在亚利桑那州，你真的可以看到这种策略产生的影响。这就是艾萨克和佐伊一直在跟进报道的内容。下面是艾萨克。
All over the country, almost everywhere I called-- Georgia, Florida, Texas-- there were local level Republican officials who are getting flooded with new people wanting to become precinct committee members. A lot of these officials didn't know about the precinct strategy. They hadn't seen Steve Bannon's interview with Dan Schultz. And they were frankly a little puzzled by what was happening, like Kathy Petsas in Maricopa county, Arizona.
在全国各地，几乎我联系过的每一个地方——佐治亚州、佛罗里达州、得克萨斯州——都有地方级别的共和党官员被大量想成为选区委员的新人淹没。许多官员并不了解选区策略。他们没看过斯蒂夫·班农对丹·舒尔茨的采访。坦率地说，他们对正在发生的事情感到困惑，就像亚利桑那州马里科帕县的凯西·佩萨斯一样。
It was a rainstorm of people who all of a sudden, out of the woodwork, were wanting to suddenly become precinct committee members. I used to get like two or three people a month. And now I was getting 40 to 50.
突然之间，涌现出大量人马，他们想要成为选区委员。我以前每月大概只收到两三份申请，而现在我收到了40到50份。
Yeah. Oh, I'm not kidding. I see your look. No, 40 to 50 applications like thrown at me. Sometimes in a week.
是的。噢，我没开玩笑。我看到你的表情了。不，就是40到50份申请扔向我。有时就在一周内。
Kathy is old school, an OG Republican, she says. She was stuffing mailers for the party when she was 12 or 13. When she was a teenager, she was awarded Outstanding Teenage Republican. She got to meet President Reagan in the Rose Garden. Puts a McCain sign on her lawn every year for his birthday.
凯西是老派作风，她说自己是“元老级”共和党人。她在12或13岁时就开始为党派装填信件。十几岁时，她被授予“杰出共和党青少年”称号。她在玫瑰园见过里根总统。每年麦凯恩生日时，她都会在草坪上放上他的标牌。
She's been a precinct committee member for 40 years. As district chair, she had 454 precinct committee slots. And she had a clear idea of who a precinct committee member should be-- someone who knows the neighborhood and the people in it, someone knowledgeable about local Republican politics.
她担任选区委员已有40年。作为区主席，她有454个选区委员名额。她对选区委员应该是什么样的人有明确的想法——熟悉街区和居民的人，了解当地共和党政治的人。
And Kathy wanted to know who are all these new people who suddenly wanted to do this unglamorous job. She started taking the applicants out to meet one on one.
凯西想知道，所有这些突然想做这种枯燥工作的新人到底是谁。她开始单独约见这些申请者。
I ended up having coffee with 156 people I've never met before and about a-- I mean, sometimes it was multiple times a day I would go and meet with people. They would start bringing up the things that we've all heard about, the videos, the this and that, and no, this is out there and you really should watch this, and you should read this, to try to explain to me how I really didn't know anything about the election and the process.
我最终和156个我从未谋面的人喝了咖啡，有时一天要见好几次人。他们会开始谈论我们都听说过的那些事情、视频，各种乱七八糟的，说“不，这些就在网上，你真的应该看看这个，应该读读那个”，试图向我解释我其实对选举和程序一无所知。
Basically saying there's a conspiracy rigging this election.
基本上是说有一个阴谋操纵了这次选举。
Yes.
是的。
You've been involved in local politics for a long time but you don't understand the depth of this conspiracy.
你在当地政治中深耕已久，但你不了解这个阴谋的深度。
I don't understand. No, they would-- yeah, and so we would have an interesting conversation. I don't mind paying for their coffees. It's interesting. No one rational-- no one who has voted over and over and over again actually believes that.
我不了解。不，他们会——是的，所以我们会进行有趣的对话。我不介意为他们的咖啡买单。这很有趣。没有理性的人——没有那些一次又一次投票的人会真的相信这个。
To be clear, not all the new applicants thought the election was stolen. But a lot of them did. And Kathy thought what they were saying was nuts. As the district chair, Kathy had the authority to appoint the new precinct committee members or not. Other chairs in other districts were like, cool, whatever. Sign them up. But Kathy decided she was going to screen the new people.
需要明确的是，并非所有的新申请者都认为选举被窃取了。但他们中的很多人确实这么认为。凯西认为他们说的话简直疯了。作为区主席，凯西有权决定是否任命新的选区委员。其他区的主席觉得无所谓，反正就签了。但凯西决定要对新人进行筛选。
And after every meeting, I would go back and just kind of look at-- maybe I had to look up their voter history, only to find out that some of them actually weren't registered Republicans. Some-- many had only recently registered to vote, had never voted. But in a coffee or a meeting or something with them, they would tell me about massive fraud they'd seen.
每次会面后，我都会回去查他们的选民记录，结果发现其中一些人甚至不是注册的共和党人。一些——许多人只是最近才注册投票，从未投过票。但在咖啡会谈或会议上，他们却会告诉我他们所看到的巨大欺诈。
And I'd think she's never voted. You know? I felt like it's my-- I'm the one signing off, right? I want to feel pretty comfortable about what I'm signing off on. And it's my prerogative. It says in our bylaws, it's my choice.
我会想，她从没投过票，你知道吗？我觉得这是我的责任——我是签字的人，对吧？我想对自己签名的内容感到安心。这是我的特权。我们的章程里写着这是我的选择。
So those people who just registered to vote, talking about massive fraud, pleasure to meet you. See you around. Kathy's going to look for someone else to fill that slot.
所以对于那些刚注册投票就大谈特谈大规模欺诈的人，很高兴认识你。回见吧。凯西会寻找其他人来填补那个名额。
This was also your sneaky criteria for eliminating some of these new Stop the Steal people, I feel like.
我觉得这也是你用来淘汰一些“停止窃选”新人的“狡猾”标准。
Who's been sneaking? It wasn't sneaky. How could that be sneaky?
谁狡猾了？这并不狡猾。怎么会狡猾呢？
I guess was it's like-- I think what I mean by the word sneaky is, like you could say if you believe the election was stolen, then you don't get to be--
我想说的是——我用“狡猾”这个词的意思是，如果你相信选举被窃取了，那你就不能——
It was a standard. It was a fair standard. You want to talk about the election, I want to talk about it with people who actually participate in elections.
这是一个标准。这是一个公平的标准。你想谈论选举，我想和真正参与选举的人谈论它。
Kathy didn't think people who were telling her about massive voter fraud would make good messengers for the party. They weren't wild about her either.
凯西认为那些向她大谈大规模选民欺诈的人，不会成为党的优秀传声筒。他们对她也没什么好感。
I spoke with one of the people Kathy was trying to keep out of the precinct committee, Merissa Hamilton. And when I brought up Kathy's name, Merissa lunged, lobbing the worst insult you could against a fellow Republican.
我采访了凯西试图拒之门外的其中一人，梅里莎·汉密尔顿。当我提起凯西的名字时，梅里莎猛然反击，对这位共和党同僚发起了最恶毒的攻击。
Kathy Petsas supported-- quietly supported Biden. She wouldn't let people become precinct committeemen if they supported Trump. So have you interviewed Kathy Petsas?
凯西·佩萨斯悄悄支持拜登。如果人们支持特朗普，她就不让他们成为选区委员。你采访过凯西·佩萨斯吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
She's lying to you. So Kathy Petsas did not support Trump. She told people to vote for Biden. She was a Never Trumper, a bold Never Trumper.
她在撒谎。凯西·佩萨斯根本不支持特朗普。她告诉人们投票给拜登。她是那种激进的“反特朗普派”。
Kathy actually seems to be a Once Trumper. Says she supported him in 2016, just not anymore. Still, Kathy insists she never supported Biden and didn't tell anybody else to either. The idea is anathema to Kathy.
凯西实际上似乎曾经支持过特朗普。她说2016年支持过他，但现在不再支持了。尽管如此，凯西坚持说她从未支持过拜登，也没有告诉任何人去支持他。这个想法对凯西来说是极其厌恶的。
And she would only invite--
而且她只会邀请——
Merissa says she heard that Kathy even recruited Democrats to switch parties and become Republicans, in order to install them as precinct committeemen under her control, to keep control of her legislative district. This may have happened in only one case, I think. And I believe Kathy didn't know the Republican donor she recruited was actually a registered Democrat in her mad dash to recruit PCs who didn't believe the election was stolen.
梅里莎说她听说凯西甚至招募民主党人改换党籍加入共和党，以便将他们安插为她控制下的选区委员，从而保持对她立法区的控制。我想这种情况可能只发生过一次。我相信凯西在疯狂招募不相信选举被窃取的选区委员时，并不知道她招募的那个共和党捐款人实际上是注册的民主党人。
Anyway, Merissa found out the kinds of people Kathy was recruiting all while people like her were being ignored, and she was mad. Also, Kathy stopped holding regular PC meetings. She says because of COVID. Merissa thinks it was to keep people out, so she wouldn't have to hear from those who disagreed with her within her legislative district. People say LD here.
总之，梅里莎发现了凯西招募的人员类型，而像她这样的人却被忽视了，这让她很生气。此外，凯西停止举行定期的选区委员会议，她说是因为新冠疫情。梅里莎认为这是为了把人们关在外面，这样她就不用听到区内持不同意见者的声音了。这里的人称之为“立法区”（LD）。
I felt that the frustrations that we saw with Stop the Steal came from people not knowing how to operate their government, not knowing how to participate. But if you're living in an LD where the chair won't let you participate, then of course it's going to manifest into something like Stop the Steal. Because people are going to have no other outlet than to just be mad.
我觉得我们看到的“停止窃选”带来的挫败感，源于人们不知道如何运作他们的政府，不知道如何参与。但如果你住在一个主席不让你参与的区，那么这种挫败感自然会演变成“停止窃选”之类的东西。因为人们除了愤怒之外别无出路。
This feud isn't just Kathy versus Merissa. Everywhere you go, there's some version of old school Republicans getting overrun by MAGA election deniers at this ground floor precinct level of the party. Merissa believes the election was compromised. We'll never know who won, she says, but thinks of herself as more reasonable than other Stop the Stealers, and a data expert of sorts because of work she's done in the past in supply chain management.
这场争斗不仅仅是凯西与梅里莎之争。无论你走到哪里，都有某种老派共和党人在这种基层选区层面被MAGA选举否定论者取代。梅里莎相信选举受到了损害。她说我们永远不会知道谁赢了，但她自认为是比其他“停止窃选”者更理智的人，并且由于过去在供应链管理方面的工作，她认为自己算是某种数据专家。
Right after 2020, she launched her own research project into how many dead people were voting. She claimed to have found 33. The attorney general then looked at it and found that only one of those was real. It wasn't a nefarious ballot harvester from the Democrats. It was a Republican who'd voted her recently deceased mother's ballot, and she was indicted. Merissa says Kathy ridiculed any research into the 2020 election, which made her especially mad. Kathy says she has no idea what Merissa is referring to, but Kathy doesn't have any patience for that kind of research, it's true.
2020年后不久，她发起了自己的研究项目，调查有多少死人参与了投票。她声称发现了33例。总检察长随后进行了调查，发现其中只有一例是真的。那不是民主党人的邪恶选票收割者，而是一位共和党人投了她刚过世母亲的选票，她被起诉了。梅里莎说凯西嘲笑任何关于2020年选举的研究，这让她特别生气。凯西说她不知道梅里莎指的是什么，但诚然，凯西对那种研究确实毫无耐心。
You know, she's one of those who gloms on to-- hey, here's an idea that everybody's making hay out of, and I'm going to do it, too. Because I don't have anything else going on, I might as well do this.
你知道，她就是那种会抓住——嘿，这是一个大家都想从中获利的想法，我也要参与其中——的人。因为我没什么别的事可做，不如做这个。
Yeah.
是的。
And so that's her deal. She's a good grifter, really good grifter.
这就是她的那一套。她是个优秀的骗子，非常优秀的骗子。
Harsh, Kathy.
话说得有点重，凯西。
But it's true. It's sad. She could do good, but she chooses to mislead people. That-- I have no space for that.
但这是事实。很可悲。她本可以做些好事，但她选择了误导他人。对于那种行为，我无法接受。
Merissa started rallying other PCs and wannabe PCs who'd been blocked by Kathy Petsas to do something about her.
梅里莎开始集结其他被凯西·佩萨斯拒之门外的选区委员和准选区委员们，想对她采取行动。
And I was like, so what do you want to do? And he was like, we're firing Petsas. And I said, OK. Let's just get people organized to work in the district.
我当时问，那么你想做什么？他说，我们正要开除佩萨斯。我说，好。让我们组织起来在区里工作吧。
They called a meeting, a meet and greet, she called it. Others called it a resistance meeting.
他们召开了一次会议，她称之为“见面会”。其他人则称之为“抵抗会议”。
We had almost 40 to 50 people show up. It quickly turned into a very loud, rowdy conversation. They wanted to fire Kathy Petsas. They were mad that she wasn't letting them participate. These are active. These are active sitting PCs that are elected PCs.
几乎来了40到50人。会议很快变成了一场非常大声、喧闹的对话。他们想开除凯西·佩萨斯。他们因为她不让他们参与而感到愤怒。这些都是活跃的、在任的、民选的选区委员。
Then Merissa and her crew found a workaround in the bylaws, a way to go over Kathy's head-- to get people onto Kathy's precinct committees. She could send the applications to the Republican county chair, who wasn't on team Kathy.
然后梅里莎和她的团队在章程中找到了一个变通办法，一种绕过凯西的方法——把人们塞进凯西的选区委员会。她可以把申请直接发给共和党县主席，而那个主席不是凯西阵营的。
Then she could approve it and give it to the recorder's office.
然后她就可以批准申请并交给记录员办公室。
You got 100 to 200 precinct committeemen appointed that way?
你们用这种方式任命了100到200名选区委员？
Yes.
是的。
That's what Merissa says. Kathy says it was more like 25 to 30 people who got in over her head. In any case, that's how Merissa and a whole bunch of new Stop the Steal recruits got on Kathy's committee. Kathy was trying to jam a lid on a pot that was boiling over.
这是梅里莎说的。凯西说大约只有25到30人是绕过她进去的。无论如何，这就是梅里莎和一大群“停止窃选”的新人进入凯西委员会的方式。凯西当时正试图压住一个即将沸腾的锅盖。
Even before this attempt to take over precinct committee positions, the Arizona Republican Party was pretty dominated by MAGA people. And after they tried to recall the Republican elected officials who certified the election, and after they spent millions of dollars to recount ballots by hand, their next target was this election, the midterms. They wanted to put Stop the Stealers in office who would actually do in future elections what Republican officials wouldn't do in 2020.
即使在这次接管选区委员职位的尝试之前，亚利桑那州共和党就已经被MAGA人士牢牢掌控了。在他们试图罢免认证选举的民选共和党官员，并花费数百万美元手工重新计票之后，他们的下一个目标就是这次中期选举。他们想让那些真正会做共和党官员在2020年没做的事的“停止窃选”者进入职位。
Because when I'm governor, we're going to take a sledgehammer to these damn electronic voting machines in Arizona.
因为当我当选州长后，我们将对亚利桑那州这些该死的电子投票机动用大锤。
That's Kari lake, former local news anchor, now a candidate for governor. She said she would not have certified the 2020 election results. Same goes for Mark Finchem, a candidate for secretary of state, which is the top elections official. Finchem is also an Oath Keeper who was at the Capitol on January 6, though he says he wasn't involved in the violence.
那是卡里·莱克，前当地新闻主播，现在的州长候选人。她说她不会认证2020年的选举结果。国务卿候选人马克·芬奇姆也是如此，他是选举最高官员。芬奇姆也是一位“誓言守卫者”，曾出现在1月6日的国会大厦，尽管他说他没有参与暴力事件。
Both Lake and Finchem want to get rid of vote counting machines, get rid of voting by mail. If they take office, they'd be in the position to refuse to certify future elections. These are the candidates that the new precinct committee people are generally supporting. In the primary, they had competition from more mainstream establishment Republicans, politicians who didn't claim the election was stolen, people Kathy supported.
莱克和芬奇姆都想废除投票计数机，废除邮寄投票。如果他们就职，他们将有权拒绝认证未来的选举。这些就是新的选区委员们普遍支持的候选人。在初选中，他们受到了来自更主流的建制派共和党人的竞争，那些没有声称选举被窃取的政客，也就是凯西支持的那类人。
[DOORBELL RINGS]
[门铃声]
Kathy.
凯西。
Hi. How are you? I'm Kathy.
嗨。你好吗？我是凯西。
A few days before the August primary, Kathy is out door knocking, getting out the vote for Karrin Taylor Robson, establishment candidate running against the aforementioned election truther, Kari Lake. Kathy is the most determined, maybe desperate door knocker I've ever met. Almost seven days a week for months now, she's door knocking. She wears the same big sunhat each day, washes her vote t-shirt most nights. It's almost a full time job, seems like.
八月初选前几天，凯西正在挨家挨户敲门，为凯琳·泰勒·罗布森拉票，这是建制派候选人，正与前面提到的选举阴谋论者卡里·莱克竞争。凯西是我见过最坚定、或许也是最绝望的敲门者。过去几个月里，她几乎每周七天都在敲门。她每天戴着同一顶大遮阳帽，晚上洗她的竞选T恤。这似乎成了全职工作。
Today, she's brought Beau with her, running for secretary of state. Says he was recruited by the business community of Phoenix because the real Republicans are concerned that the Trump endorsed Oath Keeper, Finchem, is leading in the polls.
今天，她带来了竞选国务卿的博。他说他是被凤凰城商业界招募的，因为真正的共和党人担心特朗普背书的“誓言守卫者”芬奇姆在民调中领先。
We're with the Republican Party.
我们是共和党的人。
I'm a precinct committee member. I'm here for Beau Lane. Beau and I actually were teenage Republicans together at Central High School. And Karrin Robson Taylor, who's also a fellow native Arizonan, and she's running for governor of the state of Arizona.
我是选区委员。我来这儿是为了支持博·莱恩。其实博和我当年在中央高中时还是共和党青少年组织的朋友。凯琳·泰勒·罗布森也是亚利桑那本地人，她正在竞选亚利桑那州州长。
I've seen a lot of them.
我见过很多这种人了。
Have you have you made a decision on governor yet?
你们对州长候选人有决定了吗？
No. I'll tell you, we need some changes here. That's for sure.
没有。我告诉你，我们需要一些改变。那是肯定的。
Well, I hope that--
嗯，我希望——
Change is not really what Kathy is selling, unfortunately. We only stop at one house where someone's outwardly enthusiastic for her candidate, Karrin. At our last stop, Kathy leans over a fence as a woman explains why she'd never vote for her.
遗憾的是，凯西推销的并不是“改变”。我们只在一家住户门前停下来，那里的人公开支持她的候选人凯琳。在最后一站，当一位女士解释她为什么永远不会投票给凯琳时，凯西靠在栅栏上。
I was considering her, but she did two things that I found unacceptable. One is actually putting Pence up with her. I'm sorry. I have very little respect for that man. And god, I can't even remember the other one right now, but she did two things, and that was one of them.
我本来在考虑她，但她做了两件我无法接受的事。一是把彭斯带上。抱歉，我对那个男人一点尊重都没有。天哪，我甚至记不起另一件事是什么了，但她确实做了两件事，而那是其中之一。
If she's bringing in people that I have no respect for, and I've also done some research. She's getting a lot of out-of-state money. And I'd much rather see in-state money.
如果她带来我不尊重的人，而且我还做了一些研究。她正在筹集大量外州资金。而我更希望能看到本州资金。
Well, so is Kari Lake, by the way.
顺便说一下，卡里·莱克也是。
I don't care about-- I don't want that. Thank you.
我不在乎——我不想要那个。谢谢。
Well, these are other people. I've pulled out her information.
嗯，那是其他人。我拿出过她的信息。
I'm more than capable of doing my research.
我有能力做我的研究。
All right. Well, would you consider voting for me for secretary of state?
好吧。那么，你会考虑投票给我当国务卿吗？
I would consider voting for you.
我会考虑投给你。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You have not yet offended me.
你目前还没有冒犯到我。
And so do you think you're going to vote for Kari Lake then?
那么你觉得你会投票给卡里·莱克吗？
I'm not certain.
我不确定。
Well, please think about Karrin again. We would appreciate your consideration of her because we know her personally. We know that she would be a great executive. She has the right skills. She has executive leadership.
好吧，请再考虑一下凯琳。我们会感谢你的考虑，因为我们私下认识她。我们知道她会成为一名出色的行政长官。她有合适的技能。她具备行政领导力。
She's a lawyer.
她是位律师。
Well, Kari Lake read content on the news.
嗯，卡里·莱克以前是在新闻里念稿子的。
Yes, she did. Which I don't admire any media, but I do admire somebody who says enough is enough and I'm not going to do it anymore.
是的，她念过。我不欣赏任何媒体，但我欣赏一个敢说“受够了，我不干了”的人。
She was never in the trenches. She's somebody who when we were trying to get Republicans elected for president, she--
她从不在前线。她是一个当我们试图让共和党人当选总统时，她——
Somebody had a job where she voted for Obama and I don't care. People get to change their mind. They get to smarten up. I did.
有人曾经做过那种投票给奥巴马的工作，我不在乎。人们有权改变主意。他们可以变得更聪明。我就变了。
OK. Well, good luck. And thank you very much.
好的。好吧，祝你好运。非常感谢。
Thanks for being a Republican.
感谢你支持共和党。
And as we walk away, we hear a distinct "fuck you" called after us. Back in the car, they're moving on to the next neighborhood.
当我们走开时，我们听到身后传来一句清晰的“去你的”。回到车里，他们正前往下一个社区。
Do you ever think you're being like--
你有没有想过你是不是在——
In a bad movie? [LAUGHS] Like if I'm in a nightmare? Like, how in the world did everything turn on its head?
在一部糟糕的电影里？[笑] 就像我做噩梦一样？到底是怎么回事，一切都乱套了？
Well, do you?
嗯，你有吗？
I do. You know, what's hard is that we had a great group of congressmen from Arizona. And now we have sort of this back-bencher kind of group that went off on these crazy conspiracy theories.
我有。你知道，难过的是我们曾经有一群来自亚利桑那州的优秀议员。而现在我们有了这一群陷入疯狂阴谋论的后排议员。
I don't know. I mean, this is your party. Like, this is where the new energy in the party is coming from, all this stolen election stuff.
我不知道。我的意思是，这是你的党。这些关于选举被窃取的言论正是党内新能量的来源。
If the party really is serious about winning, then they look at who are the best candidates that can win a general election. We are not here-- there is a big group of us. We are not here for half time.
如果这个党真的想赢，那他们就该看看谁是能在普选中获胜的最佳候选人。我们不是为了搞半场秀而来的——我们有很大一群人。
Arizona is known as a fairly conservative state, at least until 2020. But actually only about a third of the state's registered voters are Republicans. A little less than a third are Democrats. The rest are independents. So whoever wins the general has to win with independents.
亚利桑那州一直以相当保守著称，至少在2020年之前是这样。但实际上，该州只有约三分之一的注册选民是共和党人。不到三分之一是民主党人。其余是独立选民。所以无论谁赢得普选，都必须赢得独立选民的支持。
Kathy thinks the Kari Lakes of the world can't do that. But that's not who's voting in the Republican primary, not who's filling up the precinct slots in the local Republican Party.
凯西认为像卡里·莱克那样的人做不到这一点。但投票的人并不是普选中的独立选民，而是共和党初选中的选民，不是在当地共和党内部填补选区席位的人。
One of the biggest things these Stop the Steal newbies are doing, now that they're part of the party organization at the bottom rung as precinct committee people, is that they're setting up an infrastructure to watch all the voting locations in the midterms, to catch the fraud they didn't catch in 2020.
这些“停止窃选”的新人们现在已经是党组织最底层的选区委员了，他们做的最大的事情之一就是建立基础设施，在中期选举中监视所有投票点，以捕捉他们在2020年没抓到的欺诈行为。
They've signed up as official Republican Party poll watchers at voting locations. On primary day, outside one of those locations, a big suburban church in Mesa, we meet up with Peggy Dumas, someone who never paid attention to her precinct until she just became a committee member.
他们已经注册为投票点的官方共和党监票员。在初选日，在梅萨市的一个大型郊区教堂外，我们见到了佩吉·杜马斯，她以前从没关注过自己的选区，直到最近才成为委员。
She's got her snacks, her knitting, a notebook, and a pen to take notes. It's her first time poll watching. She picked a quiet polling place. I thought Peggy would be excited to get a piece of the action, to catch the cheaters red handed. But actually she didn't want that.
她带了零食、针织品、笔记本和笔用来记录。这是她第一次担任监票员。她选了一个安静的投票点。我以为佩吉会很兴奋能参与其中，要把骗子当场抓获。但实际上她不想那样。
You know, I get worked up. You know me. And they'd probably throw me out.
你知道，我很容易激动。你了解我的。他们可能会把我赶出去。
Basically, she's scared she's going to hulk out.
基本上，她是怕自己失控发火。
I have to confront somebody, it's not going to get pretty. So I have to watch my temper.
我不得不去和人对峙，那不会好看。所以我必须控制脾气。
Like, what do you imagine happening?
你想象会发生什么？
Not really nothing. I think-- I think it's because they know we're watching.
其实没什么。我想——我想是因为他们知道我们在盯着。
Going with her as she voted just before her shift, Peggy was super suspicious that something was going to go down. She brought her own pen to vote, because in 2020, some of the polling places provided Sharpie pens. And there was a conspiracy theory that the machines couldn't read those ballots.
和她一起去投票时，佩吉超级怀疑会有什么勾当发生。她带了自己的笔去投票，因为在2020年，一些投票点提供了马克笔。当时有一种阴谋论说机器读不出那些选票。
OK, what kind of pens are we talking about?
好的，我们说的是哪种笔？
Well, the pen is in there.
嗯，那笔就在那里。
They're felt-tip.
是毛笔头的那种。
No, I'm not using felt-tip. That's not happening.
不，我不用毛笔头。那绝对不行。
Peggy is a classic new precinct committee member. Before it was the Sharpies, it was the birth certificate.
佩吉是典型的选区委员新人。在马克笔之前，是出生证明。
I really got involved in it probably since-- I was involved in the Tea Party back during Obama.
我真正参与其中大概是从——奥巴马时期我就参加过茶党。
Why are you doing air quotes at Obama?
为什么提到奥巴马时你要打引号？
Because you don't even want to know. You don't want to go into all that. That's done and over with. There's nothing we can do about it. [LAUGHS] That's over. So that's what got me involved, then and then of course with this election in 2020.
因为你根本不想知道。你不想深入了解所有这些。那都已经结束了。我们无能为力。[笑] 那结束了。所以就是这些让我参与进来的，然后当然就是2020年的这次选举。
This was a tough time for Peggy, in a way. She says she quit her job during the pandemic. She thought she might be ready to retire. Her job was, she helped people who were underwater figure out how to pay off their debts.
这对佩吉来说是一个艰难的时期。她说她在疫情期间辞职了。她以为自己准备退休了。她的工作是帮助那些房贷入不敷出的人找出还债的方法。
She lives alone with her dogs, whom she dotes on. And she ended up spending a ton of time on her phone, reading about the election being stolen by nefarious actors. Like a lot of people I talked to, the radicalizing moment for Peggy was the moment that Fox called the election for Biden so early. Like, it just seems so obvious to her that the fix was in. There must be more Trump voters than Biden ones in Arizona, long car caravans of them, rallies with thousands and thousands of people.
她和狗独自生活，非常疼爱它们。她最终花了大量时间在手机上阅读关于邪恶势力窃取选举的信息。像我采访的许多人一样，佩吉激进化的转折点是福克斯电视台那么早就宣布拜登获胜。这在她看来太明显了，肯定是预谋好的。亚利桑那州必须有比拜登更多的特朗普选民，长长的汽车车队，成千上万人的集会。
The only way Biden could have won is cheating. And for Peggy, just the frustration that nobody did anything about it. She saw the Bannon video. She signed up as a PC.
拜登获胜的唯一方式就是作弊。而对佩吉来说，最令人沮丧的是没人对此采取行动。她看到了班农的视频，就报名做了选区委员。
The PC strategy is the way to take and elect the right people, get the right people elected.
选区委员策略是夺取和选出正确的人，让正确的人当选的方式。
OK.
好的。
Period. Get the RINOs out. I don't like them either. I dislike the RINOs worse than the Democrats. You're supposed to be a Republican, and you don't support us. I dislike them worse. Because as far as I'm concerned, they're traitors.
就这样。把共和党建制派（RINO）踢出去。我也不喜欢他们。我讨厌建制派胜过讨厌民主党。你本来应该是共和党人，却不支持我们。我更讨厌他们。因为据我所知，他们是叛徒。
Now that all these people who believe there's fraud everywhere are going to be stationed inside the polls, I wanted to find out what instructions they were getting. What were they going to do once they were there? We tried getting into one of these trainings in Arizona, but the state party wouldn't let us. But this is happening all over the country. It's the same idea, and we were able to listen in on a training in Georgia.
现在，所有这些相信到处都是欺诈的人都要驻扎在投票站内部了，我想弄清楚他们得到了什么指令。他们到那儿之后要做什么？我们试图参加亚利桑那州的一场培训，但州党部不让进去。但这在全国都在发生。这是同样的想法，我们得以监听了一场佐治亚州的培训。
Constitution says to not interfere with the process. And yet we're supposed to watch very keenly the emptying of a dropbox.
宪法说不要干扰进程。然而我们要非常敏锐地监视投票箱的清空。
OK, so if you see somebody coming in with a large number of ballots--
好的，如果看到有人带着大量选票进来——
Hang on. The deal with this-- in lots of states, including Georgia, it's illegal to deliver other people's ballots, except family and household members. There are a lot of conspiracy theories about Democrats going around with big stacks of fake ballots and sticking them in dropboxes. So if that's what you see, here's what the trainer says you should do.
等等。这个协议是——在许多州，包括佐治亚州，代他人提交选票是违法的，除了家人和家庭成员。有很多关于民主党人带着大叠假选票贴在投票箱上的阴谋论。所以如果你看到了，培训师说你应该这样做。
You go immediately to the poll manager. And you question them and say, I think I saw somebody come in and drop off more than one ballot and maybe a few more than one ballot, and see what they do.
你立即去找投票经理。你质疑他们并说，我看到有人进来投了不止一张选票，可能比一张多得多，看看他们怎么做。
So I wouldn't run after the person and ask them any questions or talk to them. I would go outside. And I would take a picture of them, and I would take a picture of their license. OK, and take a picture of their car, as much evidence as we could get.
我不会追着那个人跑去问他们问题或和他们交谈。我会到外面去。我会拍下他们的照片，拍下他们的车牌照。好的，尽可能多地收集证据。
This is the point they keep coming back to over and over-- gather evidence that Republicans can use in lawsuits to challenge the results, not just in this county in Georgia but everywhere.
这是他们反复提到的重点——收集证据，共和党人可以用这些证据在诉讼中挑战结果，不仅是在佐治亚州的这个县，而是到处都可以。
So then we could take that and open an investigation, and use that as evidence, right? But do not talk to them. Do not ask them questions. Do not confront them. Do not talk to any voters.
然后我们就可以拿着这些证据开启调查，对吧？但不要和他们说话。不要问他们问题。不要和他们对峙。不要和任何选民说话。
I'm not sure that following someone out to their car and taking pictures of their license plate wouldn't lead to a confrontation. But the thing that really struck me was the people taking the training. They weren't shying away from the action like Peggy. They sounded like they were spoiling for a fight. They wanted to catch wrongdoers in the act.
我不确定追着人到车位并拍下车牌照就不会导致对峙。但真正让我震惊的是参加培训的人。他们不像佩吉那样回避行动，他们听起来像是渴望战斗。他们想当场抓获作恶者。
I just want to say the feeling that I get from this poll watching thing is that we're watching a mugging and all we're doing is taking definitions.
我只想说，从这种监票的事情中我得到的感受是，我们就像是在看一起抢劫案，而我们唯一做的就是在定义这些行为。
You know, you're exactly right. We're not allowed to say anything.
你知道，你说得完全正确。我们不被允许说任何话。
We're describing the assailant and being able to turn it over to the police.
我们在描述袭击者，并能够将其交给警察。
Who aren't going to do anything about it.
警察是不会对那件事做任何事的。
An hour later, and then hope that they do-- yes, exactly.
一小时之后，然后希望他们会——是的，完全正确。
Well this is where--
嗯，这就是——
But if this is what we're here for--
但如果这就是我们在这儿的目的——
No, it's not. It's not.
不，不是。不是。
If this is the definition of this job, watcher, where we are noting and declaring and documenting, then I get it.
如果这就是监票员这个职位的定义，我们只需要记录、声明和证明，那我就懂了。
So that is the simplistic explanation. But if there's a problem, we can address it right away. We have attorneys, and we are not going to wait, and we're not going to wait for a lame secretary of state to not do anything.
所以这是最简单的解释。但如果有问题，我们可以立即解决。我们有律师，我们不会等，我们也不会等一个平庸的国务卿什么都不做。
I don't want to give you the wrong impression. Most of this training was pretty by the book, a PowerPoint with lots of boring details about the state law. The poll watchers get long, detailed checklists of all the little things they're supposed to write down and photograph, even the serial numbers for the zip ties that are used to lock up the voting machines, tons of stuff that could be used in a lawsuit challenging the results.
我不想给你错误的印象。大部分培训都是按规程来的，PPT里有很多关于州法律的枯燥细节。监票员得到长长的、详细的检查清单，上面写满了他们应该写下和拍下的每一件小事，甚至是封锁投票机所用的扎带的序列号，有大量可以在挑战结果的诉讼中使用的证据。
Back in Arizona, I'm doing a ride along with another first time poll watcher on primary day.
回到亚利桑那州，初选日我正陪着另一位首次参加监票的人一起执行任务。
You know, it's pretty simple. You just watch for things that are out of the ordinary. I have binoculars if I need them.
你知道，这很简单。你只需要观察不寻常的事情。如果需要，我带了双筒望远镜。
Marc's not an official poll watcher with the Republican Party. He's operating sort of off the books. He volunteers with We the People AZ Alliance. It's a group co-founded by one of the newer district chairmen. Marc's whole job during the primary is to drive around in an enormous black car and observe polling places from the parking lot, looking for infractions. He takes notes in a little book.
马克不是共和党官方的监票员。他基本上是“非正式”操作的。他是“我们亚利桑那联盟”的志愿者。这是一个由一位新任区主席共同创立的组织。马克在初选期间的全部工作就是开着一辆巨大的黑色汽车观察停车场里的投票点，寻找违规行为。他在一本小册子里做笔记。
Will you tell me what are you writing down?
你能告诉我你在写什么吗？
One of the poll watchers leaving. That's all. You're a journalist, aren't you?
一个监票员离开了。就这样。你是记者，对吧？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
OK. Where was the follow-up question?
好的。后续问题在哪？
How did you know it was a poll watcher?
你怎么知道那是监票员？
Uh-huh. What just walked behind us? Without looking.
嗯。刚才有什么东西在我们身后走过？别回头。
Well, there was a voter. Because he has the green envelope.
嗯，有一个选民。因为他拿着绿色的信封。
OK. Good. How many?
好的。很好。有多少？
It looked like two.
看起来是两个。
Very good.
非常好。
But yeah, how did you know it was a poll watcher?
但是，你是怎么知道那是监票员的？
Because it's one of us. That's why.
因为那是我们的人。就是这样。
OK.
好的。
How many is she carrying?
她带了多少？
I didn't see.
我没看见。
OK. She's carrying one. How many are those two carrying?
好的。她带了一个。那两个带了多少？
I can't see.
我看不到。
Oh, OK. None. They're going in to vote.
噢，好的。没有。他们进去了投票。
OK. [LAUGHS]
好的。[笑]
Marc dates his distrust of the government back to 911. One of the many tattoos that covers his arms commemorates the towers.
马克对政府的不信任感可以追溯到9·11。他手臂上覆盖的众多纹身之一就是为了纪念世贸大厦。
Is there anything you could see out here with your own eyes that would convince you that the fix isn't in, that there's not cheating?
有没有什么是你亲眼看到的，能让你相信一切没有预谋，没有作弊的？
I guess I'm just suspicious of everything. You have to have eyes that everything is wrong.
我想我只是对一切都持怀疑态度。你必须戴着有色眼镜去看，认定一切都是错的。
We head to another polling station. When we pull out, someone replaces us, apparently.
我们前往下一个投票站。当我们驶出时，显然有人顶替了我们。
Somebody is coming, yes.
有人来了，是的。
Oh, wow. Is there someone-- there can't be someone at every single spot. Is there?
噢，哇。有没有人——不可能每个点都有人吧？是吗？
I'm just going to say this, that the evildoers do not know, will not know whether there is or isn't. And I have to leave it there.
我只想说，作恶者不知道，也不会知道这里到底有没有人。我只能说这么多。
At the next place, we see something suspicious. Someone may be campaigning inside the 75-foot perimeter. They appear to be right on the line to me. Marc's trying to snap a good picture of them with their faces to include in his report.
在下一个地方，我们看到了可疑的事情。有人可能在75英尺的限制区内拉票。在我看来他们就在那条线上。马克正试图拍下一张他们正脸的好照片，以便包含在他的报告中。
OK, see?
好的，看到没？
Yeah.
嗯。
All right, come on. Honey, one more time. There it is. All right. We're going to do this. Stay buckled up, because we're going to go.
好了，过来。亲爱的，再来一次。在那儿呢。好的。我们要做这个。系好安全带，因为我们要走了。
He jumps out of the car. I have no idea why. I know he told me not to, but I follow him. He takes a selfie with them and then comes back to the car. He's clearly mad at me.
他跳下车。我不知道为什么。我知道他告诉我不许动，但我跟着他。他去和他们自拍了一张，然后回到车里。他显然在生我的气。
I told you to stay in the car.
我告诉过你待在车里。
I'm sorry.
抱歉。
Now he thinks we're from some news cast.
现在他觉得我们是哪家新闻台的。
I was confused. I didn't know what you were doing. I didn't want to miss it.
我当时很困惑。我不知道你在做什么。我不想错过它。
You have a windshield in front of you.
你面前有挡风玻璃。
I know, but it's radio.
我知道，但这毕竟是广播。
He's writing down his report. 4:28, he's whispering. Which is the time. We're burned at that place now, he says.
他正在写报告。4点28分，他低声说。那是时间。我们那个点现在曝光了，他说。
When you opened that door, I lost complete control of the situation. And I know you don't fully understand--
当你打开那扇车门时，我失去了对局势的完全控制。我知道你并不完全理解——
In 0.4 miles, turn left onto--
前方0.4英里，左转进入——
I know you don't fully understand why Marc is agitated to the level he is, but one of them is the safety.
我知道你并不完全理解为什么马克会焦虑到这种程度，但其中之一是安全问题。
You're going to be doing this at the general election, too?
大选的时候你也会做这个吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Are you worried about that?
你担心吗？
Yeah.
是的。
What are you worried about?
你在担心什么？
That the election's going to get stolen again. Did you ever watch a video of President Trump being in this rotunda, this great hall, and he's got a bunch of people around him and he said something about the storm. And a reporter asked, what's the storm, Mr. President? And his response was, you'll see. What do you think the storm is?
担心选举再次被窃取。你有没有看过特朗普总统在圆形大厅，这个大厅，周围围着一群人，他提到“风暴”的视频？有记者问，风暴是什么，总统先生？他的回答是，你会看到的。你觉得风暴是什么？
I don't know. What does it mean to you?
我不知道。这对你意味着什么？
At the moment it was said, it was just said.
说的时候，它只是被说了出来。
Right.
对。
Time rolls on, it's very obvious what the storm is. And I'm sorry that you don't see it.
时间推移，风暴是什么就很明显了。我很抱歉你没看到。
Well, what is it?
嗯，那是什么？
We're the storm, the people. Think about it. I can't give you all the answers, lady.
我们就是风暴，人民。想想看。我不能给你所有答案，女士。
Anything of note in Marc's reports is put into a spreadsheet, I'm told. So if it's like someone gets out of a red Honda with a whole bunch of ballots, and then later someone else sees a red Honda and someone getting out with a bunch of ballots, it'll be caught. And they can investigate further if that's maybe an illegal ballot harvester.
据我所知，马克报告中的任何重要内容都会被放入电子表格。所以如果有人开着一辆红色本田带着一堆选票下车，后来又有人看到一辆红色本田和人带出一堆选票，就会被抓到。如果那可能是非法的选票收割者，他们可以进一步调查。
[CHATTERING]
[闲聊声]
It's primary night. I'm with Kathy at the watch party for her candidate, the establishment candidate, Karrin Taylor Robson. We're in a ballroom at a really fancy resort. They're serving canapes, duck, and Gruyere tarts. The crowd here is feeling great right now because Karrin Taylor Robson is leading Trump endorsed Kari Lake.
初选之夜。我和凯西一起在她的候选人、建制派候选人凯琳·泰勒·罗布森的观看派对上。我们在一家非常豪华的度假村的宴会厅里。他们提供小吃、鸭肉和格鲁耶尔奶酪馅饼。这里的人群现在感觉很好，因为凯琳·泰勒·罗布森领先于特朗普背书的卡里·莱克。
Karrin lives in LD 28, Kathy's district.
凯琳住在第28立法区，凯西的选区。
LD 28, we're going to call it the establishment, which it is.
第28立法区，我们称之为建制派，确实如此。
This is definitely the establishment.
这绝对是建制派。
This is right here. Well, you know what? Guess what. They work hard. They give money. And they get people elected. And if that's the establishment, we'll take it all day long.
就在这儿。嗯，你知道吗？猜猜看。他们工作努力，他们捐钱。他们让人当选。如果这就是建制派，我们整天都接受它。
Kathy and I go to the bar for a drink. So I stop recording for a while. As the night goes on, the results start to change as more election day ballots are counted. Kari Lake is closing the gap. Finally, she takes the lead.
凯西和我去吧台喝了一杯。所以我停止了录音一段时间。随着夜色加深，计票结果随着选举日选票的统计开始改变。卡里·莱克正在缩小差距。最后，她领先了。
For a few minutes, I'm alone with Kathy. She's tearing up and staring off blankly. I'm going to be sick, she says at one point. I can't be a PC in this. I turn my recorder on again.
几分钟里，我和凯西单独待着。她热泪盈眶，眼神呆滞地望着前方。我要吐了，她某时说道。我无法作为一个选区委员面对这个。我再次打开录音机。
OK.
好的。
Well, what just happened, we had our candidate for governor is now down by 1,033 votes after leading all night. She may not pull it out. And this was our hope at having a competent, capable, pragmatic candidate for the governorship here in Arizona, and not have to deal with somebody who just makes up lies and spews them as her own personal truth. So I'm disappointed right now.
好吧，刚才发生了什么，我们的州长候选人在领先了一整晚后，现在落后了1033票。她可能赢不了了。这是我们希望在亚利桑那州拥有的一位称职、能干、务实的州长，而不必应对那种只会满口谎言并将其当作个人真理的人。所以我现在很失望。
After the primary, Kathy has to think about what to do. She isn't going to go out knocking on a thousand doors for these nominees who she can't stomach. There are some local candidates she'll campaign for and registering people to vote. She's been approached to sign on to some lists of Republicans endorsing the Democratic candidates, but Kathy won't go there.
初选结束后，凯西不得不考虑该怎么办。她不会去为那些她无法忍受的候选人敲一千扇门。有一些当地候选人她会为其竞选，并帮助人们注册投票。有人曾接触过她，让她在一些支持民主党候选人的共和党人名单上签名，但凯西不会那样做。
She isn't the party chair in her district anymore. She actually decided not to run again, but the newbies didn't let her go quietly anyway. They made their move with a formal proceeding against her a few months before the primary, before her term as district chairman ended.
她不再是区里的党主席了。她实际上决定不再连任，但新人们还是没让她悄悄离开。他们在初选前几个月，在她的区主席任期结束前，对她采取了正式行动。
So we're going to proceed with the hearing, and we'll go from there.
所以我们要继续进行听证会，然后从那儿开始。
Kathy describes this proceeding as a kangaroo court. It was a trial overseen by the county chair of the Maricopa County Republican Party, MCRC, and adjudicated by a committee of her fellow district chairmen.
凯西将这次程序描述为“袋鼠法庭”。这是一场由马里科帕县共和党县主席（MCRC）监督的审判，并由她的选区主席同事委员会裁决。
Whoa, whoa, whoa. It says in the rules that she has to say whether she pleads guilty or not guilty.
哇，哇，哇。规定里说她必须说她认罪还是不认罪。
Not guilty.
不认罪。
OK, thank you. You may proceed.
好的，谢谢。你可以继续。
Upfront, there's a long table with the executive committee, like a tribunal, with small tables around the room with the other district chairmen, who are like the jurors. Kathy sits at the table nearest the door. The charge against her? She was accused of endorsing a Democrat in a Phoenix city council race last year.
前面是一张长桌，坐着执行委员会，就像一个法庭，房间周围的小桌子坐着其他选区主席，他们就像陪审员。凯西坐在靠近门口的桌子旁。对她的指控是什么？她被指控去年在凤凰城市议会竞选中支持了一名民主党人。
Ms. Pestis, how long have you been a PC and how long have you been a member of the MCRC?
佩萨斯女士，你担任选区委员多久了，你加入MCRC多久了？
Excuse me, could you please pronounce my name properly?
不好意思，你能把我的名字读准确吗？
I would love to. I don't know how to.
我很乐意。我不知道怎么读。
How long have you been a precinct committee member?
你担任选区委员多久了？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
About seven months.
大约七个月。
OK. I've been one 40 years.
好的。我已经做了40年了。
Congratulations.
恭喜。
Point of order. Please answer the question.
程序问题。请回答问题。
Please pronounce my name properly.
请把我的名字读准确。
Please tell me how to pronounce your name.
请告诉我怎么读你的名字。
It's spelled P-E-T-S-A-S.
拼写是P-E-T-S-A-S。
And it is pronounced?
发音是？
"Pet-sass."
“Pet-sass”。
That is exactly what I said.
那正是我说的。
You said "pes-tass."
你说的是“pes-tass”。
OK, go ahead.
好的，继续。
And I am Chairman Petsas.
而且我是佩萨斯主席。
Eventually, the prosecutor gives up on the Socratic method and just reads aloud from Kathy's quote in the newspaper, saying something nice about the Democratic city council candidate. Kathy argues that this quote is not an endorsement, and the race wasn't even partisan. One of Kathy's supporters points out that Kari Lake, the gubernatorial candidate who the Stop the Stealers love, she supported Obama in 2008.
最终，起诉人放弃了苏格拉底式的提问方法，只是大声读出报纸上引用凯西的话，说了一些关于那位民主党议员候选人的好话。凯西争辩说这些话不是背书，而且那场竞选甚至不是党派竞选。凯西的支持者指出，受“停止窃选”者喜爱的州长候选人卡里·莱克曾在2008年支持过奥巴马。
The county chair's not having it. I don't know what this has to do with anything, she says.
县主席听不进去。我不知道这和任何事情有什么关系，她说。
I don't know what this has to do with anything. Leave that one out.
我不知道这和任何事情有什么关系。跳过那个。
I think that means, is this similar kangaroo court going to happen to Ms. Lake, since this is a year later, and you're bringing something up like this. Are you going to do the same thing to Ms. Lake if she's governor? So what are you going to do? No, stop. Answer the question, Kevin.
我想意思是，既然这已经是一年后的事了，你提出了这样的问题，类似的“袋鼠法庭”会不会发生在莱克女士身上。如果她是州长，你会对她做同样的事吗？所以你会怎么做？不，停下。回答问题，凯文。
Kathy's asked to step out of the room. She refuses, challenges the secret ballot.
凯西被要求离开房间。她拒绝了，并质疑秘密投票。
I make the motion that this vote be roll call vote and be in the minutes of who voted yay or nay.
我提议这次投票必须是唱名投票，并记录在案是谁投了赞成还是反对。
She goes down fighting, but she goes down. The verdict is guilty. Kathy gets stripped of her voting rights as a precinct committee member. We talked about it later on the phone.
她在抗争中落败了。结论是有罪。凯西被剥夺了作为选区委员的投票权。后来我们在电话里谈过。
I mean, it feels terrible, you know? It feels gut-wrenching. This isn't what you work hard for, to be treated this way.
我的意思是，感觉糟透了，你知道吗？感觉肝肠寸断。这不是你努力工作的目的，被这样对待。
Kathy still goes to her district meetings, even though she's not the chair anymore. The new chair is one of the guys who plotted to overthrow Kathy. There's an ongoing dispute over whether she's allowed to vote on anything. She spends the meetings needle pointing. The meetings open with prayers now. That's new.
凯西仍然去参加她的选区会议，尽管她不再是主席了。新任主席就是那个策划推翻凯西的人之一。关于她是否被允许在任何事情上投票一直存在争议。她参加会议时在做针线活。现在的会议以祈祷开始。那是新的。
We pray for those that are volunteering to watch the vote. We pray that if there is any wrongdoing it would be caught and stopped. We thank you and pray for each of the precinct committee people.
我们为那些自愿监视投票的人祈祷。我们祈祷如果有任何不法行为，它会被发现并停止。我们感谢并为每一位选区委员祈祷。
So Kathy is gritting her teeth, refusing to give up because she's sure the party under this new leadership is bound to implode. And when it does, she wants to be there to pick up the pieces. We talked about it with her and her husband Bill over dinner after the meeting.
所以凯西咬牙切齿，拒绝放弃，因为她确信在这一新领导层下的党注定会分崩离析。而当它破灭时，她想在那里收拾残局。会议后我们在晚餐时和她以及她的丈夫比尔谈到了这一点。
You know, we're optimistic it'll pass. I don't know. It's probably not this cycle. It might be another cycle or two, but it will pass.
你知道，我们很乐观它会过去的。我不知道。可能不是这个周期。可能是下一个周期或两个，但它会过去的。
I don't know.
我不知道。
It has to.
它必须过去。
Well, first of all, Trump's 77, 78.
嗯，首先，特朗普77、78岁了。
But Kari Lake's 52.
但卡里·莱克才52岁。
Yeah, but without Trump, there's not Lake. I mean, I know they're trying to make the movement without Trump, like to survive it. But I'm not as optimistic for them that that will happen.
是的，但没有特朗普，就没有莱克。我的意思是，我知道他们正试图让运动在没有特朗普的情况下延续。但对于他们能否实现这一点，我没那么乐观。
I told Bill I wasn't so sure. Making the MAGA movement endure without Trump is what the precinct strategy is all about. It's making election denial a permanent fixture of the GOP, institutionalized within the party organization itself, so deeply ingrained that you can't extract it. You can't just lop off the head. It's MAGA all the way down.
我告诉比尔我没那么确定。让MAGA运动在没有特朗普的情况下存续，正是选区策略的核心。它正让选举否定论成为共和党的永久固定组成部分，将其制度化在党组织本身内，植入得如此之深以至于你无法剔除。你不能只砍掉头。这自上而下都是MAGA。
So we're taking over the Republican Party with the precinct committee strategy. We're taking over all the elections. Suck on this!
所以我们正用选区委员策略接管共和党。我们正接管所有的选举。吞下这个吧！
Thank you, Steve Bannon. Isaac Arnsdorf, is a national political reporter at the Washington Post. Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our show. Isaac is working on a book about the MAGA movement trying to take over the Republican Party and America. It's called Ground Game. It'll be out next fall.
谢谢你，斯蒂夫·班农。艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫是《华盛顿邮报》的全国政治记者。佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人之一。艾萨克正在写一本关于MAGA运动试图接管共和党和美国的一本书。书名是《地面游戏》。将于明年秋天出版。
Coming up, righteous middle schoolers monitoring a teacher, who of course is supposed to be monitoring them. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，正义的初中生正在监督一名老师，当然，老师本该是监督他们的。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, watching the watchers, people deciding on their own that it is their job to make sure that bad things don't happen, and then beginning their own surveillance of suspected wrongdoers. We have arrived at Act 2 of our show. Act 2, I'll Be Watching You.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，监视监视者，人们自己决定他们的工作是确保坏事不会发生，然后开始对自己怀疑的作恶者进行监视。我们已经来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《我会监视你》。
Sixth grade isn't that old, but it's old enough to tell right from wrong. And it's old enough to know that adults aren't always perfect. And at Davisville Middle School in Rhode Island, this one sixth grader couldn't help but notice that one of his teachers was doing stuff that just felt a little weird.
六年级还没那么大，但足以分辨是非。足以知道成年人并不总是完美的。在罗德岛州的戴维斯维尔中学，这位六年级学生忍不住注意到他的一位老师做的事情看起来有点怪。
Much, much later, the teacher would be removed from the school for his behavior. But at this stage, early on, this sixth grader was seeing certain things for the first time. Like at Halloween.
很久很久以后，那位老师因为他的行为被学校开除了。但在早期阶段，这位六年级学生第一次看到了一些特定的事情。比如在万圣节。
He was making remarks about some of the girls' costumes and makeup that were coming off as creepy and flirtatious.
他会对一些女生的服装和妆容发表评论，这些话听起来令人毛骨悚然且轻浮。
What did he say?
他说了什么？
Like getting in close to them and saying how they're-- this girl's thing looked ridiculous. He was making fun of her in a way to flirt with her.
比如靠得很近，说这些女孩的装扮看起来很可笑。他在嘲笑她，方式却是为了和她调情。
And he was standing very close to her physically?
他当时在身体上站得离她很近吗？
He was just-- he was just getting in closer, and he was kind of leaning in a way where it looked-- it just seemed creepy. Something seemed off about it. You could just sense it. I don't know. It seemed like she was uncomfortable by it. Like, nervously laughing at it.
他只是——他只是靠得更近了，他倾身的方式看起来——这只是显得很诡异。感觉有点不对劲。你就是能感觉到。我不知道。看起来她对此很不舒服。就像在紧张地笑着一样。
Every time this teacher did other things, he says, the kinds of stuff the kids notice, he asked a girl to take off her shoe and wiggle her toes for him, made an unsettling joke about how everybody should come to school in their bathing suits, and as the school year continued, that one girl from Halloween was a special target.
他说，每次这名老师做其他事情时，都是那种孩子们会注意到的事情，他要求一个女孩脱掉鞋子为他动动脚趾，还开了个令人不安的玩笑，说每个人都应该穿泳衣来学校，随着学年继续，万圣节时那个女孩成了特别的目标。
And I would remember him always stopping the class to make remarks about her or her appearance, or calling her pet names, making a play on her name. Put it in nursery rhymes or songs. He just started conversation with her individually in front of the whole class, like talking about stuff that was not related to class, just to make her laugh.
我会记得他总是停下课堂对她或她的外表发表评论，或者给她起昵称，玩弄她的名字。把它编进童谣或歌曲里。他只是在全班同学面前和她开始单独对话，比如谈论和课堂无关的事情，只是为了让她笑。
You can notice she's nervously laughing or blushing at it. Other kids in the class were weirded out by it. Everybody sits there in awkward silence as you do that.
你可以注意到她对此紧张地笑着或脸红。班上的其他孩子对此感到很古怪。当你这样做时，每个人都坐在那里陷入尴尬的沉默。
Did you ever talk to her about it?
你有跟她谈过这件事吗？
Not that year, no. But she did make comments the next year about how she hated when he would do that.
那年没有。但第二年她确实评论过，说她讨厌他那样做。
He says other girls made comments, too.
他说其他女孩也发表过评论。
They would say like, oh, he's weird. They wouldn't use creepy. He's weird to us. He's weird. I don't like him. I don't like him being weird. At first in sixth grade, I questioned maybe this is just normal, how teachers act, how some treat girls. But my friends all confirmed. They're like, no, this guy's creepy.
她们会说，噢，他很怪。她们不会用“诡异”这个词。他给我们的感觉很怪。他很怪。我不喜欢他。我不喜欢他表现得那么怪。起初在六年级时，我质疑这是否只是正常的，老师的行事风格，有些人如何对待女孩。但我所有的朋友都证实了。他们说，不，这家伙很诡异。
I had said it to some of my friends on the bus, some people at the bus stop, too. And they'd be like, oh, yeah. I noticed that, too. He's really creepy. Did you know he said blah, blah, blah? He did blah blah, blah. And I was like, OK, it's obviously not just me thinking.
我也对公交车上的一些朋友，甚至公交车站的一些人说过。他们会说，噢，是的。我也注意到了。他真的很诡异。你知道他说过什么吗？他做过什么什么。我就想，好吧，显然不仅仅是我一个人这么想。
And it wasn't just the way this teacher was with the girls. The sixth grader says that he was kind of a jerk with the boys. He says any kind of off task behavior would get you reprimanded if you were a boy, sent to the office. He says a teacher actually bragged that so many kids had complained about him in the past for being strict. He said they could try themselves. Wouldn't do any good.
不仅仅是这位老师对待女孩的方式。六年级学生说他对男孩很苛刻。他说任何不专心的行为都会让你受到责骂，如果你是男生，就会被送到办公室。他说老师甚至吹嘘过去有多少孩子投诉过他太严格。他说他们可以自己试试。没用的。
All this bothered this sixth grader enough that he went to two different adults. One of them was his mom. And he didn't go into a lot of depth, but he told them this teacher is a creep, flirts with the girls in class. He's a pedo. And both adults were like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Take a breath.
所有这一切让这位六年级学生感到足够困扰，他去找了两个不同的成年人。其中一个是他的妈妈。他没深入讲，但他告诉他们这位老师是个变态，在班上调戏女生。他是个恋童癖。两个成年人都说，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。先喘口气。
So they're like, don't make such accusations. Don't throw such stuff around because that's a very serious accusation. And that's perfectly understandable. I understand that.
所以他们说，不要做出这样的指控。不要随便乱扔这种话，因为那是非常严重的指控。这是完全可以理解的。我理解。
He and his friends couldn't let it go, though. They'd talk about it when they'd hang out, when they were online playing Minecraft or Super Smash Brothers. It just seemed wrong.
但他和朋友们无法放手。他们在一起玩《我的世界》或《超级马里奥兄弟》在线时会谈论它，也会开玩笑。这看起来就是不对劲。
And so, lacking any power to do anything else, they talked about it and joked about it. Finally, they decided to do the one thing you can do when you can't fix what's wrong with the world but still feel a strong sense of outrage. They became watchers. They decided to document everything the teacher did with the girls that seemed weird or inappropriate to them in a Discord channel they set up.
所以，由于没有权力做任何其他事情，他们谈论它并开玩笑。最后，他们决定做一件事，当你无法解决世界上错误的事情但仍然感到强烈的愤怒时，你能做的一件事。他们成为了观察者。他们决定在他们设置的一个Discord频道中记录下老师对女孩所做的每一个看起来怪异或不恰当的事情。
Discord, if you don't know, is a messaging platform. They called the Discord channel--
Discord，如果你不知道，是一个消息传递平台。他们给Discord频道起名为——
Pedo Database.
“恋童癖数据库”。
Did you guys think, oh, this is-- we came up with a great name.
你们当时觉得，噢，这——我们想出了一个好名字。
We just did it. Yeah, we just did it because the name was funny.
我们只是做了。是的，我们只是做了，因为这个名字很有趣。
To be clear, he knows he's using the word pedo loosely. The Pedo Database was an inside joke between a small group of boys who hated this teacher because he was so harsh with them. But they were also totally serious about the way he was treating the girls.
需要明确的是，他知道自己是在随意使用“恋童癖”这个词。“恋童癖数据库”是那一小群讨厌老师的男孩之间的内部笑话，因为他对他们太苛刻了。但他们对老师对待女孩的方式也是完全认真的。
And is the idea that you think you might accumulate enough evidence that you guys will go to the authorities at some point?
你们的想法是，积累足够的证据，以便将来去向当局报告吗？
I don't know what that was. I mean, in my log, we just said this is now the official chat that we will later use as evidence against him about pedophilia. That's the word I used, in case anything does come up in the future and we do turn out to be correct. And I said, whenever he said something creepy towards the girls in our class, posting quotes with the date here.
我不知道那是什么。我的意思是，在我的日志里，我们只是说这是我们以后用来作为针对他恋童癖证据的官方聊天记录。“恋童癖”是我用的词，以防将来发生什么事情，而我们最终证明是正确的。我说，每当他对我们班的女孩说些诡异的话时，就在这里贴上带日期的引用。
Logging the date was actually something they got from watching TV and movies, true crime.
记录日期实际上是他们从看电视和电影、看真实犯罪节目中学到的。
Like keeping dates, keeping times, keeping stuff logged on paper. And then we gave-- I gave an example of something he had said that day, and that's how it began.
比如记录日期，记录时间，把东西记录在纸上。然后我们给出了——我给出了他那天说过的一个例子，这就是开始。
What was the thing he had said that day?
那天他说的是什么？
He had called a girl the word-- he had said bad to them. Like, bad dog type thing, but then used her name.
他叫一个女孩那个词——他对她们说了“坏”。就像“坏狗”那类的，但用了她的名字。
Right, right. Like "bad Melanie."
对了，对了。就像“坏梅兰妮”。
Yeah, exactly. I had under it, said in a flirty way multiple times today towards multiple girls in the class, including-- and then I put the names. And evidence posts will be kind of like this. That's what I said. That was the establishing like thing there. After that, everybody just-- they understood. And they took it seriously about putting the dates and stuff.
是的，完全正确。我下面写着，那天多次对班上多个女孩以轻浮的方式说，包括——然后我写了名字。证据贴子大概就是这样的。这就是建立那种东西。之后，每个人都——他们理解了。他们非常认真地对待记录日期之类的东西。
And every few weeks, the teacher did something noteworthy enough that one of the boys would jot it down on a pad secretly, right then in class, or type it directly into Discord on his phone, adding an entry to the database log. These kids finished with that teacher, moved on to the next teacher.
每隔几周，老师就会做一些值得注意的事情，以至于其中一个男孩会偷偷地记在纸上，就在课上，或者直接输入到Discord手机里，在数据库日志中增加一个条目。这些孩子在那位老师的课上结束了，转到了下一个老师的班级。
But to keep the log going, they enlisted kids who had him the next year. And they read the new entries.
但为了让日志继续下去，他们拉拢了下一年有那个老师的学生。他们阅读新的条目。
It's not like we wanted him to say bad things, but it was satisfying when we did, because then we'd be like, all right, great, another piece for the record. Every time he said something, it's like we pictured him punching himself in the face.
并不是说我们希望他说坏话，但当他说的时候这让人满足，因为那样我们就想，好吧，太棒了，记录里又多了一条。每次他说什么，我们就像看到他在给自己脸上打了一拳。
It's interesting to me that it was all boys doing this. I would think that girls would have wanted to get in on it, if they knew it existed.
让我感兴趣的是，全都是男孩在做这个。如果女孩们知道它存在的话，我觉得她们也会想加入进来。
Perhaps they would have, but we didn't bring it up. But I'm sure maybe some of them would. We just didn't really have any girls in our friend group.
也许她们会，但我们没提。但我敢肯定也许其中一些人会。我们只是朋友圈里没女孩。
Oh, right. Right. Middle school.
噢，对了。对了。初中。
Yes, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
The reporter who broke this story and revealed the Pedo Database to the world is Amanda Milkovits of the Boston Globe. And the reason it became public, the reason she wrote a story is that in April of this year, the teacher was removed from his job and put on leave because of allegations that he'd stalked a girl, a pre-teen at the school. After that happened, there was a public appeal to families in the school for any information about other incidents involving this teacher.
揭露了这个故事并将“恋童癖数据库”展示给世界的记者是《波士顿环球报》的阿曼达·米尔科维茨。它之所以公开，她写这个故事的原因是，在今年4月，这位老师因为被指控跟踪一名女生、学校的一名青春期前女孩而被停职。在那之后，学校公开呼吁家庭提供关于涉及这位老师的其他事件的任何信息。
And my mom told me about it. And I told her, oh, well, we have this whole log my friends and I compiled. I was actually shocked. I mean, it was almost like we predicted the future when I was like, oh my god, I could-- it all paid off.
我妈妈告诉了我。我告诉她，噢，我们有这本我和朋友汇编的完整日志。我当时真的很震惊。我的意思是，这几乎就像我们预言了未来，当我说，噢我的天，我可以——一切都得到了回报。
Did you have this feeling of like, I can't believe this is happening, I can't believe that we get to use this thing?
你有没有觉得，我不敢相信这是真的，我不敢相信我们居然能用到这个东西？
Definitely.
绝对有。
Because did you think that it was ever going to pay off, that it was ever going to be used?
因为你觉得它会有回报，它会被用到吗？
Honestly I didn't think so. I mean, this guy was there for so long. No one could do anything about him. And for all I knew, they would-- when I brought this up to a lawyer, I thought maybe they would just all laugh at this.
老实说，我不觉得。我的意思是，这家伙在那里呆了那么久。没人能对他做什么。据我所知，他们会——当我把这个拿给律师看时，我以为他们会嘲笑这个。
It's a Discord chat with a bunch of people with funny profile photos and names. I didn't know if that could be used as actual evidence against someone. I was very surprised about that. Yeah.
这是一个有着一群搞笑头像和名字的Discord聊天记录。我不知道它能不能作为针对某人的实际证据。我对这个感到非常惊讶。是的。
We reached out to this teacher for an interview about all this, but he didn't return our calls or texts. One thing about this story, the name of the teacher has not been made public, or the names of the minors involved, including the boys who ran the Pedo Database. In fact, the voice that you've been hearing for this interviewee is a young actor, Azhy Robertson, who's imitating the real student as closely as possible to keep that kid anonymous.
我们联系了那位老师想进行采访，但他没回复我们的电话或短信。关于这个故事的一点，老师的名字没有公开，涉及的未成年人的名字也没有，包括那些运行“恋童癖数据库”的男孩。事实上，你听到的这个受访者的声音是一位年轻演员，阿兹·罗伯逊，他尽可能模仿那位学生以保持匿名。
Though after reporter Amanda Milkovits published her story in the Boston Globe, it was picked up widely, got passed around on social media, and, naturally, the news got back to the school.
尽管记者阿曼达·米尔科维茨在《波士顿环球报》发表文章后，它被广泛转载，在社交媒体上传播，自然地，消息传回了学校。
We had seen some people reposting it on Instagram. I think I heard a couple of people talking about-- my friend told me that his-- a lot of people in his math class were talking about it. This is a friend that was part of the log with me.
我们看到一些人在Instagram上转发它。我想我听到几个人在谈论——我朋友告诉我他的——他数学课上的很多人都在谈论它。这是跟我一起记录的朋友。
Wait a minute. And so people were talking about it at school. Do they know it's you?
等一下。所以人们在学校里讨论它。他们知道是你吗？
Not the ones that weren't involved in the log. Because obviously staying anonymous to protect the integrity of the case is a big-- is important.
那些没参与记录的人不知道。因为很明显，保持匿名来保护案件的完整性非常重要。
And so what's it like for you? You're like Clark Kent going around. You can't tell anybody you're Superman.
那对你来说是什么感觉？你就像克拉克·肯特四处走动。你不能告诉任何人你是超人。
[LAUGHS] Yeah, somewhat. I mean, I'm not really-- I didn't do this for fame. I'm not looking for that. I mean, it's cool that people know what we did, but--
[笑] 是的，有点。我的意思是，我不是真的——我做这个不是为了名声。我不是在寻找那个。我的意思是，人们知道我们做了什么很酷，但——
What are you talking about? I'm picturing you in the lunchroom, and people are talking about what you guys did. And then you have to keep your mouth shut and be like-- you can't say like, oh, that's me.
你在说什么？我脑海里浮现出你在食堂，人们在谈论你们做的事情。然后你不得不闭上嘴，表现得——你不能说，噢，那是我。
I don't overhear a lot of the background chatter, but some of my friends do. And I can imagine for them it might be like, I don't know, hard to keep their mouth shut.
我没听到太多背景闲聊，但我的一些朋友听到了。我可以想象对他们来说，很难闭嘴。
And it's not hard for you to keep your mouth shut?
对你来说很难闭嘴吗？
Not at all, no.
一点也不，不。
After the teacher got put on leave and the Pedo Database made the news, a young woman, an adult, came forward and said that she'd also been harassed by the same teacher years ago. She wrote a letter to the Pedo Database boys. She said, "when we're young, we're told that adults know best, that they know everything. Now as an adult, the only thing I know is that stupid kids just turn into even stupider adults.
在老师被停职和“恋童癖数据库”上新闻后，一位年轻女性，一个成年人，站出来说她多年前也曾被同一个老师骚扰过。她给“恋童癖数据库”男孩们写了一封信。她说：“当我们年轻时，被告知成年人最了解，他们知道一切。现在作为成年人，我知道的唯一一件事就是愚蠢的孩子只会变成更愚蠢的成年人。”
When I was a student in this teacher's class, I felt helpless against his harassment and bullying. None of the other adults took my feelings seriously, not to mention the blind eye that teachers would turn to the creepy relationships that he had with other students.
当我是这位老师班上的学生时，我在他的骚扰和欺凌面前感到无助。没有其他成年人认真对待我的感受，更不用说老师对他在与其他学生之间的诡异关系所表现出的视而不见。
Hearing that the same thing still happening in his class nearly seven years after I left leaves me feeling sad and frustrated with the school system's lack of action. Thank you so much for standing up for all the students who didn't have a voice. You're very brave for taking a stand against something you knew was wrong. And you should be very proud of yourselves for that. Thank you."
听说在我离开近七年后同样的事情仍然在他的班上发生，让我对学校系统缺乏行动感到悲伤和沮丧。非常感谢你们为所有没有声音的学生挺身而出。你们为站出来反对一件你们明知是错误的事情而非常勇敢。你们应该为此感到非常自豪。谢谢。
The boy told me that it felt good to read that. It made it feel like a bigger deal, what they'd done.
那个男孩告诉我，读到那个感觉很好。这让事情感觉像是一个大事件，他们所做的事情。
Years ago, I was friends with a political reporter at the Rand Daily Mail, the big opposition newspaper in South Africa back during the height of apartheid. They published story after story about terrible things the white government was doing back then. Over decades, it had little or no effect on the government at all. The brutality in bantustans and suppressions of dissent continued.
多年前，我和《兰德每日邮报》的一位政治记者是朋友，那是种族隔离时期南非的大型反对派报纸。他们发表了一篇又一篇关于当时白人政府所做可怕事情的故事。几十年来，它对政府几乎没有影响。班图斯坦的暴行和对异议的镇压仍在继续。
He and I talked once about what the point of publishing was in that setting. Said that even if it didn't seem to be doing much good right then, he and his editors felt that it was important that there was a record, that someone noted what was happening and wrote it down, so that later nobody could deny it happened.
我和他曾经谈过在这种情况下发表新闻的意义。他说即使当时看起来没产生多大效果，他和他的编辑们认为重要的是存在一个记录，有人注意到发生了什么并写了下来，以便后来没有人可以否认它发生过。
Can I say, OK, when I finished writing this story yesterday, that's where I ended this story. Because it seemed like a good way to capture what these middle school boys had done. But then, today on my way to work, I thought about the Stop the Stealers in Act 1 of today's show.
我可以这样说，好吧，当我昨天写完这个故事时，我就是在那里结束的。因为它似乎是捕捉这些初中男孩所做之事的最好方式。但今天在上班路上，我想到了Act 1节目里的“停止窃选者”。
And I realized how that idea, the idea that if you make a factual record of what happened, a truthful record, that in the future nobody can deny it. That idea feels like it's from just another era. Things are so different today. The Stop the Stealers continue to believe a whole set of lies about the 2020 election being stolen, and they are trying to remake the world based on denying what really happened. And I know that is not an especially uplifting note to end the show on today, but I think in dark times, it does no good to pretend that you're not living in dark times.
我意识到那个想法，如果你对发生了什么做一个事实记录，一个真实的记录，那么在未来没有人可以否认。那个想法感觉就像是来自另一个时代的。今天一切都太不同了。停止窃选者继续相信关于2020年选举被窃取的一整套谎言，他们正试图基于否认真正发生过的事情来重塑世界。我知道这不是今天节目结束时特别令人振奋的音符，但我认为在黑暗时代，假装你并没有生活在黑暗时代是毫无意义的。
[MUSIC - "WHO'S WATCHING THE WATCHERS" BY LABELLE]
[音乐 - LABELLE演唱的《谁在监视监视者》]
Well, our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. She also produced Act 2. The people who put together today's show include Chris Benderev, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Cassie Howley, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Will Peischel Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman.
嗯，我们今天的节目由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德制作。她也制作了第二幕。今天参与制作节目的人包括克里斯·本德列夫、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、卡西·豪利、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、威尔·佩舍尔、娜迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉曼。
Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Sabrina Hyman, Frank Rizzo, Stephen Richer, Vanessa Barchfield, Robert Fitzgerald, Sandra Dowling, Cheryl Rosado, Sally Grubbs, Susan Knox, the Marietta Diner, Dan Eggan, Ariel Plotnick, Sabby Robinson, Sean Carter, Marilyn Thompson, Jack Hitt, Tim Conlon, Phillip Rakita, and Emily Abbott.
我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。特别感谢萨布丽娜·海曼、弗兰克·里佐、斯蒂芬·里彻、瓦妮莎·巴奇菲尔德、罗伯特·菲茨杰拉德、桑德拉·道林、谢丽尔·罗萨多、莎莉·格拉布斯、苏珊·诺克斯、玛丽埃塔餐厅、丹·埃根、阿里尔·普洛特尼克、萨比·罗宾逊、肖恩·卡特、玛丽莲·汤普森、杰克·希特、蒂姆·康伦、菲利普·拉基塔和艾米莉·阿博特。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there are lists of favorites, videos, all kinds of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he and I went to karaoke together this week. He sang Britney Spears, but I don't know. He just never gets the lyrics right.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体收听我们750多集的存档。此外，还有各种列表、视频，各种其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org，《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我和他这周一起去唱了卡拉OK。他唱了布兰妮·斯皮尔斯，但我不知道。他总是记不对歌词。
All right, come on. Honey, one more time.
好了，过来。亲爱的，再来一次。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "WHO'S WATCHING THE WATCHERS" BY LABELLE]
[音乐 - LABELLE演唱的《谁在监视监视者》]